loose skin is a problem for many of us
but we now have a non-invasive solution
here is brittany from the jazzy wellness
to tell us more hey brittany so what
what is an ultrasound skin lift
so it uses a ultrasound to penetrate
down to the muscle
so it tightens from the inside out and
so what areas does this treat
anywhere we can do the body but our most
popular is the face and the neck
so someone comes in and let's say
they're getting their neck done how long
did the result
wow look at these before and after
photos that is incredible i'm sorry i'm
distracted by these four
before and after photos okay so how long
do these results last someone had their
neck done how long did the results last
up to five years but at that point they
don't come undone
it's the aging process will slowly start
to take over again
this is incredible how many sessions are
we doing to get these results
just one session one session that is
unreal
they look like two different people when
we see the before and after photos so
how does this compare to other
procedures that are out there
it's non-surgical non-invasive people
come and do it on their lunch break it's
that easy
and you walk out looking years younger
how long does let's talk about someone
who had their eyes done there how long
does that take
so the treatment time itself for eyes
would be about 15 minutes but if we're
doing like full face and neck
usually around an hour so talk me
through the process someone's seeing
these results
they want to get it done do you guys do
a consultation they call you how does it
work
yeah call us come in for a free
consultation you can show us the areas
you want to address
and we can come up with a treatment plan
or get you scheduled any other
advantages to having this done besides
just looking spectacular when it's all
said and done
the best part about this is that same
day you'll see some textual improvement
but for that day up to the next year
you're going to be non-stop
lifting and tightening amazing stuff
brittany we always appreciate you coming
on the show thank you very much
thank you the jazzy wellness is located
at 900 south valley view suite 100
find them online at thejazzywellness.com
and take advantage
of this special deal first 10 callers
receive 40 percent off non-surgical
facelift
in las vegas now we'll be right back